poco ha durado La tregua entre China y
Estados Unidos decretaba tras el viaje
del secretario de estado Anthony blinken
a Beijing sólo necesitó un día el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden en
dinamitar la calificando de dictador a
su homólogo chino la respuesta acaba de
llegar en la rueda de prensa diaria del
Ministerio de exteriores chinos dice que
esas declaraciones van en contra de los
hechos que suponen una violación
flagrante de los protocolos diplomáticos
y que dañan la dignidad política aún más
el portavoz ministerial ha dicho que los
comentarios son tremendamente absurdos e
irresponsables y una absoluta
provocación vaivén en un acto para
recaudar fondos en California había
explicado
Queen se había mostrado tan enojado
después de que él ordenara abatir el
globo es porque el dirigente chino
desconocía de la existencia de ese globo
y que esa ignorancia provoca una
vergüenza insuperable en los dictadores
el episodio del globo fue precisamente
el que hizo
suspender la primera visita de blinken
que estaba prevista para febrero china
tardó más de cuatro meses en darle una
nueva cita un síntoma de la creciente
desconfianza en Beijing hacia Washington
la Cumbre sin embargo fue un éxito y de
ahí salió el compromiso del deshielo sin
embargo las declaraciones de biden ponen
en peligro todo lo que se consiguió este
fin de semana en Beijing